counselors
we're now live on youtube all right
thank you chris
good morning everyone welcome to the
different building control partnership
committee i'm mike haynes i'm
chairman of the committee to start the
meeting now please with the
apologies for absence
um no apologies for absence chair okay
and uh i think uh councillor bastogne
is just joining us right thank you okay
item two on the agenda is the minutes of
the last meeting which are attached
to the agenda not particularly lengthy
so
um can't anticipate any problems anyone
wish to raise any items on the
minutes of the last meeting no
somebody like to move that they are
accepted as a correct record
that's council kimber and secondary
councillor birch
okay um nobody else so can i have
uh all those in favor please you can
raise your hand on the screen
thank you that's carried welcome hillary
see you down the bottom there now
right thank you all right okay so that's
carrick so that's
item two onto item three which is the
declarations of interest
are there any interest to be declared by
any of the members
nope okay if we can move on then to
ies 204 which is chairs announcements
um first of all i'd like to welcome
nigel hunt who's joining us today i can
see nigel on the screen i'll invite you
to speak later nigel under the
item on the agenda where uh it concerns
yourself
um and not unrelated to that the other
announcement i'd have to make is that
this is of course the last meeting that
andrew carpenter
uh will be uh with us in his role as he
is retiring
at the end of uh end of march
um i might say a bit more later but i
would say at this point obviously andrew
has been involved
for a very long time in building control
um in the conversation just before we
started today he reminded me
that he came round to inspect an
extension to my house
back in 1981 it would have been which
was a loft conversion
which is the one i'm currently sat in um
so
it's obviously still there so he must
have done
i said on his job uh or me that put it
up
um so he's obviously been here for a
very long time if it wasn't i think it
was the one in 81 because i didn't
extend it slightly in 86 but
um anyway i know um he's been with team
bridge originally since
78 uh a short trip away to plymouth for
just a few years and then
back here and obviously we're dead and
building control partnership since it
was set up
uh many years ago now and i can't even
remember when but it was um
right seemed to ring about 2003 or
thereabouts i know
it was under reg at that time and then
there was roger and then
andy's been our head for uh
some number of years so um can i
publicly on everyone's behalf
um wish andy a well-earned retirement
i'm sure you'll find lots
of other things to do and thank you very
much for all the work that you've put in
for local authorities and for building
control over the many years of service
did you want to say anything at this
point obviously you've got to get
through the meeting first before you can
relax but
uh go on andy um yeah i'll just say uh
thank you very much
uh chairman and thank you to all the
members of the committee for their
support throughout my time has had a
partnership which is
i believe it's exactly 10 years i think
it's april 2011 when i started
has had a partnership and
several of you have been involved with
the committee right
from uh well before that um
either continuously or as in your case
you would chairman before i started as
head of partnership and your chairman
again now
um so thank thanks to all of you for all
your uh
support on the way um but i'll i'll
comment further in
in part two thank you okay thank you
right um do anyone else want to say
anything we're gonna save it for later
okay we move on then yeah terry
just a quick one chairman if i may i i
think that
the initial idea for the building
control partnership which was put
forward by
reg and phil and
oh gosh that's terrible roger roger yes
uh originally i mean they would be
absolutely amazed at what we've
got grown through now and and you know
andy has done a brilliant job
in uh guiding us to where we are as as
the head of survey you know head officer
so you know i think those two gentlemen
if they were still with us
um they'd be immensely proud of what you
know their
original idea has come to and and
you know what andy has achieved since he
took over from roger's head of
partnership
yeah thank you okay thank you hillary
clinton as uh as um
no i'm not muted am i no you're i'm here
yeah yeah as team bridge and west evan
had their say
i don't want to repeat what you both
said because you both said some very
nice words
and i agree with everything you said on
on behalf of south hams
um yes andy uh you've been most helpful
to us
all along uh since you've been uh head
of the partnership
i've only had to drop you a line and
you're straight on to
any problem we've had and i've
appreciated everything you've done
we have met socially on a couple of
occasions but i won't go into those
um for obvious reasons but um yes
um thank you for everything you've done
on behalf of the three
councils and all and particularly on
behalf of southampton
okay thank you right so that's all the
councils yeah gary
uh yes just a short note of thanks also
uh
to to to andy from from myself at team
bridge uh yes it's been great working
working with you uh andy um and uh you
know the the team that you've built
that you've supported that team bridge
as well um and
all the work you've done for the for the
partnership uh
many many things and yes and do enjoy
your retirement
right thank you okay so nothing else i'm
the chairman's announcement so if i move
on now
to item five which is the operational
report
part one um so if i could hand over to
andy to go through this please
okay i'll take you through this fairly
quickly
um i'm sure you've all had a chance to
read the report so it's fairly brief but
it's the
third quarter of the year and um it just
highlights the performance of the
partnership
um we've continued to meet all our um
our pis throughout the whole period um
and uh considering we had a lockdown in
november
obviously we're not down again now um
but uh
that lockdown the construction industry
kept going
and it really didn't impact on our
workload um
so all the staff have been busy and uh
the the
the um well the income and the figures
generally
have been quite busy and we've
maintained
um the level of service that we always
strive to achieve
a couple of other things to mention uh
one of our surveyors left at the end of
september
uh he moved on to
um a a surveyor carrying out warranty
inspections and also
they carry out approved inspector work
as well
and we advertised the post and we've
successfully
managed to appoint somebody who will be
starting
i'm not sure of the confirmed date yet
but i understand it's probably in may
finally our ram covered 19
arrangements that were in place uh we've
continued to
work since the uh outbreak in the the
original lockdown
last april by
assessing inspections and where
practical
and where where sensible we've carried
out
virtual inspections rather than
physically visiting the site
which during subsequent lockdowns
including now
we continue to do we risk assess them
some physical inspections are being
carried out they're being carried out
daily
but only where it's safe to do so and
where it's necessary
if it's um if it's not so necessary if
it can be avoided then we will use
virtual means and i've put in the report
um the the guidance that the government
have given
with regard to uh carrying out
inspections by all building control
bodies
uh finally there's a comment on uh in
there
informing everybody but as you already
know that i'll be retiring at the
end of march um finally our marketing
and
events um we
obviously can't carry out any any events
for we haven't done so for a year now um
certainly not both regarding our awards
or any of our customer events etc
we are looking at arranging some online
events and webinars
etc because it's now been a long time
and it looks like that long time will
continue
so that that's that's the alternative
approach at the moment
that's all i've really got to say unless
if anybody has any questions
okay does anyone have any questions
under the part one report
you speaking henry sorry
that's the shortest report he's ever
given i think
yeah well he's obviously a bit more in
the part too yeah
he's suggesting he's dmob happy that uh
yeah
see how you can get away with the short
report
okay thanks nobody has indicated there's
anything they wish to raise on that so
if we could then move on
please to the next item which is item
six which is the
um recommendation
that under section 100 a brackets for
the local government act 1972 the press
and public be excluded from the meeting
of the particular items on the grounds
that it involves the likely disclosure
of exempt information as defined in the
relevant paragraphs
of part 1 and schedule 12a of the act
some would like to move that please
thank you it's been moved councillor
taylor secondly patrick kimber those
were the hands i saw together on my
screen other
others were up okay can i can have a
vote of hands on the screen please those
in favor
thank you that's everyone i think right
thank you that's carried
uh so we're now moving into part two so
chris you need to do whatever it is you
need to do on the
live